it's one of the most divisive issues in
the united states within hours of a
leaked draft opinion showing justices
could overturn a landmark ruling on
abortion rights protesters from both
sides gathered outside the supreme court
[Music]
it's been considering whether to
overturn the 1973 judgment known as roe
v wade that legalized abortions across
the country i'm very passionate about
being pro-life and i'm just here as an
observer to see
what the attitude is like and kind of
witness history because this is a huge
deal
it's expected to issue its ruling in
june but the draft written by
conservative justice samuel alito
suggests the top court would find the
roe v wade decision was wrongly decided
because the u.s constitution makes no
specific mention of abortion rights this
is really just tearing apart everything
that we've worked for and everything all
the change that we've worked for to
happen
it would represent a seismic shift in
u.s politics pushing decisions on
abortion rights back to individual
states
[Applause]
it could also have a major impact on
upcoming midterm elections as well as
the presidential vote in 2024 it'll be
up to the states to decide and for
example california we'll keep it legal
here but other states like texas and
others who are in the red states are
pretty that 21 states are waiting with
legislation to either restrict abortion
or to ban it all together right now at
this point they're waiting for this kind
of a decision
several conservative states have
recently joined a growing push to
restrict abortions some activists are
calling for legislation at the federal
level to protect rights so we need mass
protests in hundreds of cities across
the nation to defend rovi weight and we
also need to go on the offensive through
these mass protest actions through
workplace actions by the labor movement
for abortion and reproductive care to be
free
[Applause]
the unprecedented leak has sparked
controversy across the u.s the draft
ruling can only become final when it's
published by the court alexia o'brien al
jazeera
okay let's explore this as joining us
now from amherst in massachusetts is
laura briggs she's a professor of women
gender and sexuality studies irregularly
writes about reproductive politics
feminism and race laura briggs welcome
to the program first of all
what was your reaction to this
extraordinary news
well i wish i could say i was
disappointed but we know that the
republicans have been stacking the
courts for years
anticipating this outcome
so how long has this campaign been going
on to overturn this law and what now can
be done potentially to stop it
well since the nixon administration
um nixon thought of the idea of
politicizing the question of abortion in
this way
and in order to win republican votes but
it's also clear that whoever leaked this
draft decision
intended that people should mobilize
either to
stockpile medication for
medical abortion
or to get into the streets and
get on the pages of the editorial pages
of
news magazines and newspapers and let
the court know that the majority of
americans support
the outcome of roe v wade and legal
abortion and the kind of bodily autonomy
for pregnant people that represents
right given the majority in the united
states do not want this overturned why
is it that the republicans have been
working so i mean you say back to the
next nixon days why has it
been going on for so long
because it mobilizes a small core of
their voters
um evangelical conservative christians
in particular
who
will
get out who will be the volunteers for
the campaigns
and who will vote for people like former
president trump who otherwise i think
they would be not drawn to
in your view if this does go through
what are the implications
well what we know from the texas bounty
law is that ninety percent of the people
who were seeking abortions got them
anyway so they cross state lines or they
turn to medication abortions that they
could do in their own homes
and so what this law will do what this
particular ruling will do is turn the
question back to the states
and about a dozen states across the
south and midwest have trigger laws that
will immediately
set out to criminalize abortion
while other states like i'm here in
massachusetts will protect the right
and possibly even expand the right to
abortion
and if that happens criminalizing
abortion if that happens
what are the implications for women
around the
country well one of the things that we
know is that women will die
um women have always sought abortions um
when it wasn't the right time in their
lives to
have a pregnancy to have another baby
when they couldn't afford it
and they couldn't support it in their
lives and women have often taken
drastic measures to
to get an abortion to stop a pregnancy
and
some of them died
it's a little bit safer now than it was
before um the row era because we have
the
opportunity to
use medication abortion which women
around the world in places where
abortion is criminalized
have been using successfully and safely
it's about as safe as tylenol
well thanks for talking to us laura
briggs speaking to us from amherst in
massachusetts in the united states
thanks very much
thank you